turning to Ukraine and an extraordinary
attack on Russian soldiers by Ukrainian
forces you get using American supplied
weapons and Lee has the latest from
Ukraine and good morning
good morning almost no place in Ukraine
has been left untouched by Russia's War
driving around the former front lines
many buildings like this school are
damaged
shortly after midnight on New Year's Day
Ukrainian forces struck back dealing the
Russians a deadly blow
foreign
Rockets like those seen here flattened a
Russian military base housing troops and
storing weapons in the city of makivka
inside the Russian occupied Donetsk
region in the country's East yes in a
rare admission of military loss Moscow
claims at least 63 soldiers died while
Keith says as many as 400 were killed
and hundreds more injured the Kremlin
couldn't cover up this embarrassing blow
to Russia's war effort social media
posts carried the alleged photos of the
aftermath and Russian military bloggers
quickly condemned their own commanders
for allowing the attack to happen Jeff
Hahn is a Russia expert with the London
School of Economics the Russian regime
is trying to figure out the best way to
spend this on the one hand they don't
like to ever admit taking military
casualties on the other hand by
publicizing these numbers and keeping
them relatively high but not admitting
to the full amount they can Instead try
to rally public support
out of Revenge many ukrainians now brace
for what they believe will be a ruthless
Russian response meaning more
destruction like this Vlad
Inland Ukraine thank you very much